When someone you love has an eating disorder, relationships can start to feel very different. Conversations can become arguments, meal times can become battlegrounds, and sometimes it can feel like the illness is speaking louder than the person you know and love. Today I'm joined by Tiffany, who has personal experience of anorexia as we explore eating disorders recovery compassion and why it's so important to separate the person from the illness. Hi, welcome along to Psychology Actually, I'm Dr. Marianne Trent, a qualified clinical psychologist. I'm joined here today by Tiffany, who is a placement psychology student. Hi, Tiffany. Hi, nice to meet you, Marianne. Thanks for having me on the podcast.
当您所爱的人患有进食障碍时，人际关系可能会开始变得非常不同。对话可能会变成争吵，用餐时间可能会变成战场，有时您会觉得这种疾病的声音比您所了解和爱的人的声音更大。今天，我邀请到了蒂芙尼（Tiffany），她有厌食症的亲身经历，我们将一起探讨进食障碍的康复、同理心，以及为什么将人与疾病区分开来如此重要。您好，欢迎来到《心理学其实》（Psychology Actually），我是临床心理学家玛丽安·特伦特（Dr. Marianne Trent）博士。今天和我一起的是实习心理学学生蒂芙尼。你好，蒂芙尼。你好，很高兴见到你，玛丽安。谢谢你邀请我参加这个播客。
Lovely to be here. And thank you for pitching the podcast to me as well via LinkedIn. So we are getting together today to think about how we can stay compassionate for people that are experiencing eating disorders and also to help think about how we can help them and their families to kind of maybe externalise the eating disorder from the person because that can be so important, can't it? Yeah, definitely. I think that's one of the main things. There's a lot of self-criticism when it comes to eating disorders and I think it's so important that we realise that actually there is an individual behind those behaviours that just really needs that care, support and that love and nurturing.
很高兴来到这里。也谢谢你通过领英（LinkedIn）向我推荐这个播客。所以我们今天聚在一起，是为了思考我们如何能对那些正在经历进食障碍的人保持同理心，同时也为了帮助思考我们如何能帮助他们及其家人，将进食障碍从个人身上“外化”出来，因为这非常重要，不是吗？是的，绝对是。我认为这是最重要的事情之一。在进食障碍方面，存在很多自我批评，我认为我们意识到在这些行为背后其实有一个个体，他们真的需要关怀、支持、爱和滋养，这一点非常重要。
Please know that if you were to watch the YouTube version, we are not using any images of any low-weight people in our video because that feels really important because I know when we are well, we can look at those images and be really shocked and really sad and moved by distress. But actually those kinds of images for someone who is vulnerable to becoming unwell or is already unwell can really fuel and make things worse, can't they, Tiffany? Yeah, definitely. I think, again, when it comes to eating disorders, it is so easy to become triggered and that can obviously perpetuate the eating disorder. So it's really important that we
请知悉，如果您观看的是YouTube版本，我们在视频中没有使用任何低体重人士的图片，因为这感觉非常重要。我知道当我们健康时，看到这些图片可能会感到非常震惊、悲伤，并被这种痛苦所触动。但实际上，对于那些容易变得不健康或已经不健康的人来说，这类图片真的会推波助澜，让情况变得更糟，不是吗，蒂芙尼？是的，绝对是。我认为，同样地，当谈到进食障碍时，人们很容易受到触发，这显然会使进食障碍持续下去。所以，非常重要的是我们
kind of spread a positive message around and that's avoiding images, talk of numbers, BMI's, etc. Yeah, which obviously having worked in a service where I've worked with people who do have anorexia or low weight diagnoses, it's really hard because often people live with the medicalised way of treating people. We are asking people to step on the scales and we are trying to think about kind of is this a healthy weight? You know, are you having periods? It's really hard and I think speaking as a clinician, we used to try and have the clinicians that were doing the therapy work for that person, but then a separate staff member who would maybe do the way-ins to try and keep it a little bit separate so that you didn't feel like
传播积极的信息，这包括避免使用图片、谈论数字、体重指数（BMI）等。是的，显然，在曾与患有厌食症或低体重诊断的患者一起工作的服务机构中，这真的很困难，因为人们通常生活在医疗化的治疗方式中。我们要求人们站上体重秤，我们试图考虑这是否是一个健康的体重？你知道，你的月经正常吗？这真的很难。作为一名临床医生，我们过去常尝试让负责该患者治疗的临床医生进行治疗工作，但让另一名工作人员进行称重，试图将两者稍微分开，这样你就不会觉得
you were doing the policing. It's just a really hard area to work in and people would often ask not to see the weight. It's really hard. Yeah, I agree with that. And I think one of the biggest things that I try to do through my work is kind of, I like spread the message that eating disorders are mental health disorders, not physical health disorders. And unfortunately, the way the treatment works, it does kind of again perpetuate that
你在扮演监管者的角色。这是一个非常难工作的领域，人们经常要求不要看体重。这真的很难。是的，我同意这一点。我认为我在工作中尝试做的最重要的事情之一就是传播这样一种信息：进食障碍是心理健康障碍，而不是身体健康障碍。不幸的是，治疗方式的运作方式确实再次加剧了
kind of idea that it's based on physical measures. So it's a physical health disorder, but it's not. The physical symptoms are just a side effect of the mental condition underlying. So yeah, I think it's really important that we realise that how unwell someone is, it isn't determined by BMI, etc. It's the amount of distress around eating, around exercise, around body image. Yeah, and distress is such a powerfully important word because that is often what people just don't see.
那种基于身体指标的想法。所以它看起来像是一种身体健康障碍，但事实并非如此。身体症状只是潜在心理状况的副作用。所以，是的，我认为我们意识到一个人的不健康程度不是由BMI等决定的，这一点非常重要。它取决于围绕进食、运动和身体形象的痛苦程度。是的，“痛苦”是一个非常有力的词，因为这往往是人们看不到的。
there is so much distress. And before we started recording, we were talking about, you know, some of the helpful suggestions that are made for how to, how to kind of, you know, how to make things be different. And people are often like, well, put some butter in your pasta
这里有太多的痛苦。在开始录制之前，我们谈到了关于如何让事情变得不同的建议。人们经常说，嗯，在你的意大利面上放点黄油，
or put some single cream on your cereal. But that is obviously thought of from a caloric perspective, how can we make sure that whatever this person is eating is going to be as calorie dense as possible. But having to do that is really, really very distressing for the person who, the only sense of control they've got, because this is what this is, isn't it?
或者在你的麦片粥上加点鲜奶油。但这显然是从热量的角度考虑的，我们如何确保这个人吃的任何东西都尽可能地高热量。但对于那个人来说，不得不这样做真的非常非常痛苦，因为这是他们唯一拥有的控制感，因为这就是进食障碍的本质，不是吗？
This is what eating disorders often are about. It's about control. And this is the variable that they are having to use right now so that they can feel like they've got some semblance of control. Yeah, and again, I think that really gets forgotten about the fact that eating disorders do come down to some form of control and maybe this is control over feelings that have resulted from past traumas and actually it's not about body image it's not all about food and I think that really gets lost sometimes and it's really important that we remember that
这就是进食障碍通常的意义所在。它是关于控制。这是他们现在必须使用的变量，这样他们才能感觉到自己拥有某种程度的控制感。是的，而且我认为人们确实忘记了进食障碍确实归结为某种形式的控制，也许这是对过去创伤所导致的感受的控制，实际上它不仅仅是关于身体形象，也不仅仅是关于食物，我认为这一点有时真的被忽略了，记住这一点非常重要：
that the eating disorder is a way of coping with something that felt unbearable at the time yeah and I think also what's often not understood is that actually people with eating disorders certainly restrictive ones, actually really love food. You know, they'll be really into food and be really into thinking about good quality food and nutrition and, you know, will absolutely wax lyrical with you about their favorite restaurants or their favorite recipes when they are feeling well.
进食障碍是一种应对当时感觉无法承受的事情的方式。是的，而且我认为人们通常不理解的是，实际上患有进食障碍的人，当然是限制性进食障碍患者，其实真的很喜欢食物。你知道，他们会非常热衷于食物，非常热衷于思考高质量的食物和营养，而且当他们感觉良好时，他们绝对会和你滔滔不绝地谈论他们最喜欢的餐厅或最喜欢的食谱。
And it's almost like depriving yourself of something as a punishment or a control because that's the thing that's maybe going to hurt most. and that's often overlooked. Yeah, I agree with that. And again, like, I was that typical kind of case of, surely not me that's got an eating disorder. Like, I love food.
这几乎就像是剥夺自己的某种东西作为惩罚或控制，因为那可能是最让人痛苦的事情。这通常被忽视了。是的，我同意这一点。而且，就像我一样，我是那种典型的“我怎么可能患有进食障碍”的案例。就像，我热爱食物。
I mean, I come from a background where my mom is Japanese and, like, food was such a big part of the Japanese culture. And I loved food. I loved going out trying new recipes, try new meals. And now I'm grateful that's something that I can do again. But like you said, it felt like that was a way of punishing myself. it was something that I loved and it was so important to me and obviously controlling that and like through restriction
我的意思是，我来自一个母亲是日本人的家庭，食物是日本文化中非常重要的一部分。我热爱食物。我喜欢出去尝试新的食谱，尝试新的餐点。现在我很感激这是我又能做的事情。但就像你说的，这感觉就像是我惩罚自己的一种方式。这是我热爱的东西，对我来说非常重要，显然通过限制来控制它，
that was my way of punishing myself because I feel like I didn't deserve it. Yeah. And it's that non-intentional self-harm. We've got a whole episode on that that's a great list and a great watch if people do want to check that out. So you mentioned there yourself that you have had a history of eating disorders yourself
那是我惩罚自己的方式，因为我觉得我不配拥有它。是的。这就是非故意的自残。我们有一整集专门讨论这个话题，如果人们想看的话，那是一个很棒的列表，也是一个很棒的视频。所以你自己提到过你也有进食障碍的历史，
which has obviously sparked your interest in this into thinking about ways we could do things hopefully better and different. Would you be able to tell us a little bit about your experiences that if that feels comfortable to do so, Tiffany? Yeah, of course. So when I was 16, I began struggling with disordered eating and by the time I was 17, it had kind of turned into a full-blown eating disorder. So I was diagnosed with anorexia. And unfortunately, I just was not able to recover in the community. So I was admitted as an inpatient for about two years. And, and this was during COVID as well.
这显然激发了你对这个问题的兴趣，去思考我们如何能做得更好、更不同。如果感觉舒服的话，你能告诉我们一点你的经历吗，蒂芙尼？当然可以。我16岁时开始与饮食失调作斗争，到17岁时，它已经演变成了一种全面的进食障碍。所以我被诊断出患有厌食症。不幸的是，我无法在社区中康复。所以我作为住院病人住了大约两年。而且，这还是在新冠疫情期间。
So it was an extremely challenging time. And I'm grateful to say that I've been recovered for two years now, which is just like if you told me that about five years ago, I would have just laughed really. It didn't feel possible at the time. And I think unfortunately my recovery was quite prolonged and there probably was things that could have been different that would have led to me being fully recovered a lot quicker.
所以那是一段极其艰难的时期。我很感激地说，我已经康复两年了，如果五年前有人告诉我这一点，我真的会笑出来。当时感觉是不可能的。而且我认为不幸的是，我的康复过程相当漫长，可能有一些事情如果做得不同，会让我更快地完全康复。
I do feel like, again, unfortunately, I understand the NHS is stretched for funding. It definitely is and there are some amazing clinicians out there. But I think the understanding of eating disorders is not quite there. There were times in treatment settings where maybe there wasn't so much of an understanding of what someone might be going through from that kind of lived experience, And I think when it comes to eating disorders, it is really tricky. And I think there is a lot of tiptoeing. Am I saying the right thing?
我确实觉得，同样不幸的是，我理解英国国家医疗服务体系（NHS）的资金紧张。它确实很紧张，而且外面有一些很棒的临床医生。但我认为对进食障碍的理解还不够到位。在治疗环境中，有时可能对一个人从那种生活经验中可能经历的事情缺乏理解。我认为当谈到进食障碍时，这真的很棘手。而且我认为有很多小心翼翼。我说对了吗？
Is this unhelpful? And then maybe I just shouldn't say anything. And I think we're so sensitive to the language that people use that unfortunately it can create more conflict and it can kind of keep that eating disorder going. So I think for me I have picked up that maybe there was a bit of a lack of compassion around the language used and the approaches. But again, I do want to highlight that working with eating disorders is quite challenging. I think the treatment's quite brutal and it can feel like you're working against the individual a lot of the time.
这有帮助吗？也许我什么都不应该说。我认为我们对人们使用的语言非常敏感，不幸的是，这可能会产生更多的冲突，并可能使进食障碍持续下去。所以我认为对我来说，我感觉到在所使用的语言和方法上可能缺乏一点同理心。但同样，我确实想强调，处理进食障碍是相当具有挑战性的。我认为治疗相当残酷，而且很多时候感觉你是在与个体作对。
But it's really important, again, to remember there is someone behind those behaviours. And we're just humans like everybody else and we deserve that support. Yeah, thank you for sharing a little bit of your story there. So how do we stay compassionate and how do we begin to externalise the difficulties from the person? Yeah, I guess the first thing is like looking at the language used. When we're talking to individuals with eating disorders, I think there can be a lot of kind of frustration and anger. And this can kind of come across as they're angry and frustrated at that individual. So for me, maybe there were times where.
但同样重要的是要记住，这些行为背后有一个人。我们和其他人一样都是人类，我们理应得到那种支持。是的，谢谢你分享你的一点故事。那么我们如何保持同理心，我们如何开始将困难从个人身上外化出来？是的，我想第一件事就是审视所使用的语言。当我们与进食障碍患者交谈时，我认为可能会有很多挫败感和愤怒。这可能会表现为他们对那个人感到愤怒和沮丧。所以对我来说，也许有几次，
there was conflict between maybe my parents or the staff on the ward and I would internalise it. I'd be like, this is me that's not good enough. This is me that can't do it. I'm a failure. And obviously that like in a compassion that I had, it just became non-existent. And I think already when you have an eating disorder, like self-criticism again is something that you really struggle with. So it's really important that kind of those conversations are directed away from that individual. For me, I didn't necessarily give a name to my eating disorder because this is something a lot of people do to kind of separate the eating disorder from the individual. For me, it was kind of realizing there was this part of me that really needed that care and that support.
我父母或病房工作人员之间存在冲突，我会将其内化。我会想，是我不够好。是我做不到。我是一个失败者。显然，我所拥有的那种同理心变得不存在了。而且我认为当你患有进食障碍时，自我批评确实是你真正挣扎的事情。所以，将这些对话从那个人身上转移开来非常重要。对我来说，我不一定给我的进食障碍起了一个名字，因为这是很多人为了将进食障碍与个人分开而做的事情。对我来说，这是一种意识到我身体里有这一部分真正需要那种关怀和支持的感觉。
And this was what was kind of making me display these behaviours. This is my way of expressing that I needed support and I was struggling. So, yeah, again, it's like really expressing to that person, they're not angry at them. that angry at kind of the behaviours they're presenting. Yeah. And I like the idea that often we will become the adult that we might have needed ourselves as a child. So if we fast track a few years down the line then,
这就是导致我表现出这些行为的原因。这是我表达我需要支持和挣扎的一种方式。所以，是的，同样，这就像真正向那个人表达，他们并不生他们的气，而是生他们所表现出的行为的气。是的。而且我喜欢这种想法，即我们经常会成为我们小时候自己可能需要的那种成年人。所以，如果我们快进几年，
you may ultimately end up working in eating disorders, hopefully as a qualified clinical psychologist, is that fair to say? What adult would you hope, that a 16-year-old Tiffany would meet in a few years' time? Yeah, I guess I just want someone to really kind of validate the pain and the struggle because ultimately that's what is the most distressing and that's what you're there for. It's to kind of work through maybe the trauma that has led up to the development of an eating disorder
你最终可能会从事进食障碍方面的工作，希望成为一名合格的临床心理学家，这样说公平吗？你希望16岁的蒂芙尼在几年后遇到什么样的成年人？是的，我想我只是希望有人能真正验证这种痛苦和挣扎，因为归根结底，这是最令人痛苦的事情，而这正是你存在的意义。是为了解决可能导致进食障碍发展的创伤，
and I think connection is so important. it's about being there, listening to that individual. And we don't want solution-based kind of conversations all the time. I think it can be quite difficult. It's kind of like, okay, you get this meal plan. Did you eat this? Did you eat that? Yes, no. Kind of like onto the next thing.
而且我认为联系非常重要。这是关于陪伴，倾听那个人的心声。我们并不总是需要基于解决方案的对话。我认为这可能相当困难。这就像是，好吧，你拿到了这个饮食计划。你吃这个了吗？你吃那个了吗？是，不是。就像进入下一件事一样。
And actually we need to do more of the talking. We need to do more of the getting to know that individual. So I think for me it is about having someone who cares about who you are. other than the eating disorder and really trying to strengthen that part of you. And in doing so, it will kind of weaken that part that needs that care and that support. And because you'll be feeling that connection with others. So ultimately, you can live life how you want to live it. So for me, I feel like in the future, as a clinician,
实际上我们需要做更多的交谈。我们需要做更多了解那个人的工作。所以我认为对我来说，这是关于拥有一个关心你是谁的人，而不是关心进食障碍，并真正尝试加强你那一部分。这样做，它会削弱那部分需要关怀和支持的部分。因为你会感受到与他人的联系。所以最终，你可以按照你想要的方式生活。所以对我来说，我觉得在未来，作为一名临床医生，
if I was treating someone like I was when I was 16, that's what I would have needed. I don't need someone to always kind of be in the drive trying to find answers. I just want someone to listen to me. Yeah, and there's usually some element of trauma that has meant that there's been a vulnerability for this, that's been a seed planted in the soil that's germinated when the conditions are right. So we really need to be working with people to help them to process their trauma, to grieve for that and to find hopefully more adaptive ways of of healing themselves and of coping so that so that the what seems like the impossible can happen and you described it to me
如果我像我16岁时那样对待某人，那才是我所需要的。我不需要有人总是试图在驾驶座上寻找答案。我只是想有人听我说。是的，通常会有某种创伤因素，这意味着对此存在脆弱性，就像在土壤中种下了一颗种子，当条件合适时就会发芽。所以我们真的需要与人们合作，帮助他们处理创伤，为之哀悼，并希望找到更具适应性的自我疗愈和应对方式，这样看似不可能的事情就能发生。你向我描述过
as seeming impossible that that you as a 16, 17 year old, 18 year old could ever begin to hold the idea that you might feel comfortable looking at yourself when you were a, what people might describe as a healthy, healthy body weight. But that has happened for you, hasn't it? Yeah. So when I was struggling, I was a lot of the time I was obviously told, like, when you reach a healthy body weight, like your focus turns away from your body and you'll actually feel okay with it and you'll be at peace with it. And you'll be living your life and not thinking about your body all the time.
作为16、17、18岁的你，似乎不可能开始接受这样一个想法：当你处于人们可能称之为健康的体重时，你可能会对自己感到舒适。但这确实发生在你身上了，不是吗？是的。所以当我挣扎的时候，我很多时候显然被告知，当你达到健康的体重时，你的注意力就会从身体上转移开，你实际上会对自己感觉良好，并与之和平共处。你会过自己的生活，而不是一直想着你的身体。
And I was like, oh, yeah, yeah, whatever. have to say that kind of thing. But actually now obviously coming through the other end, I'm like, yeah, actually you were right kind of thing. It's like I don't think about my body. Definitely not any more than kind of an average person would. I live my life how I want to live it. And my body is like one of the least important things about me.
我当时想，哦，是啊，是啊，随便吧。不得不说那种话。但实际上现在显然走到了另一端，我想，是的，实际上你是对的。就像我不去想我的身体。绝对不会比普通人想得更多。我按照我想要的方式生活。我的身体是我身上最不重要的事情之一。
None of my friends care about how I look, you know. So I think, yeah, it's a real turning point. and I do hate to admit when I'm wrong, but yeah, definitely they were right when they were saying that. And obviously it's really hard when you're in the moment. Like, I mean, obviously going through and coming out the other side, but I still know when I was unwell, you can't think entirely rationally at the time and it does feel impossible. So again, it's just trying not to be self-critical over that. And that's something, I guess, being recovered now, I look back and I'm like, oh, if I just did that,
我的朋友们都不关心我的长相，你知道。所以我想，是的，这是一个真正的转折点。我确实讨厌承认我错了，但是的，他们说得对。显然，当你身处其中时，这真的很难。我的意思是，显然经历过并走到了另一边，但我仍然知道当我身体不适时，你当时无法完全理性地思考，这确实感觉是不可能的。所以同样，这只是尽量不要对此进行自我批评。我想，现在康复了，我回过头来看，我想，哦，如果我只是那样做了，
if I just did that, but it's important again to remain compassionate to yourself. Yeah. Would you say, looking back, would you say it's a little bit like OCD that you kind of need to almost stay using the approaches forever because OCD will often look for a vulnerability to kind of creep back in again if you've had it? Would you say that kind of eating disorders are similar? Or once you're recovered, is it just, are you kind of one and done, would you say? Yeah, I think it's a difficult one. I do think it can vary from person to person, but I think for me, I don't have like eating disorder thoughts as such, but there is always in the back of my head kind of like I don't want to ever slip back into it. Like I think it's being more cautious than maybe the average person when it comes to food. I think I'm definitely more sensitive to other people's cues as well. So kind of like if I see someone who's maybe, you know, not eaten a certain meal at the time that maybe everybody else is meeting, eating.
如果我只是那样做了，但保持对自己同理心仍然很重要。是的。回过头来看，你会说这有点像强迫症（OCD）吗？如果你曾经患过强迫症，它通常会寻找脆弱点再次潜入，所以你需要几乎永远使用这些方法？你会说进食障碍类似吗？还是说一旦你康复了，就是“一次性解决”？是的，我认为这是一个难题。我确实认为这因人而异，但对我来说，我没有那种进食障碍的想法，但我的脑海里总是有一种想法，我不想再滑回去了。我想这比普通人在食物方面更谨慎。我认为我对别人的暗示也绝对更敏感。所以，如果我看到有人可能，你知道，没有在大家都在吃的时候吃某顿饭。
And then I'm kind of thinking like, oh, what's going on there? So it might not even necessarily be about myself, but I think just having that awareness. And again, for me, it's kind of like I'm always making sure that I've eaten enough. And I think it's just kind of like, it's not actively having thoughts, but it's like, I don't ever want to go back there. So it's just being more aware about that. I know social media can be full of fitness stuff and exercise stuff. at the moment too, can't it?
然后我就会想，哦，那里发生了什么？所以这甚至不一定与我自己有关，但我认为只是拥有那种意识。而且对我来说，我总是确保我吃得足够多。我认为这就像，不是主动有想法，而是像，我再也不想回到那里了。所以这只是对此更加警觉。我知道社交媒体现在可能充满了健身和运动的内容，不是吗？
Yeah, I think with exercise as well, it took me a long time to get back into exercise because I had such kind of like toxic relationship with it. And I think when I first started going back, I was very hypervigilant about it. I was thinking, am I doing this for the right reasons? So I think, again, it is kind of like a stepped process and it's just always being aware. And of course, like being a young woman in her 20s, like I'm still going to compare myself to other people and how other people look. But it's just about kind of like comparing yourself
是的，我认为在运动方面，我花了很多时间才重新开始运动，因为我和它有那种有毒的关系。而且我认为当我刚开始回去时，我对它非常警惕。我在想，我做这个是为了正确的理由吗？所以我认为，这确实是一个分阶段的过程，只是要时刻保持警觉。当然，作为一个20多岁的年轻女性，我仍然会把自己和别人比较，比较别人的长相。但这只是关于比较你自己，
but then not acting on any thoughts that come up and realising that actually these are normal thoughts. Like unfortunately we are kind of in a society where we're made to compare each other's bodies and it's just about being able to focus on like your values and who you are as a person and really recognising that the body isn't the most important thing about us because it definitely isn't.
但随后不对出现的任何想法采取行动，并意识到实际上这些是正常的想法。不幸的是，我们处于一个被迫比较彼此身体的社会中，这只是关于能够专注于你的价值观和你作为一个人的身份，并真正认识到身体不是我们身上最重要的事情，因为它绝对不是。
Yeah. And it's that idea that, yes, we may be human. Yes, we may both be female, but they might be the only things we have in common. You know, there are people out there in the world who are studying to be medics. There are people out there who are studying astrophysics. There are people who are studying to be yoga teachers. There are people who are studying to be psychologists. how can we possibly begin to compare all of those people just because they happen to be male, just because they happen to be female. It's like comparing an apple and a banana.
是的。这就是那种想法，是的，我们可能是人类。是的，我们可能都是女性，但这可能是我们唯一的共同点。你知道，世界上有人正在学习成为医生。有人正在学习天体物理学。有人正在学习成为瑜伽老师。有人正在学习成为心理学家。我们怎么可能仅仅因为他们恰好是男性，仅仅因为他们恰好是女性，就开始比较所有这些人？这就像比较苹果和香蕉。
The two things are not the same. Yeah, exactly. And I think that's a massive thing for me. Like comparison was definitely the fief of joy for me. In fact, it was like the fief of just life in general. I mean, I compared myself to my sister a lot when I was growing, up and I think this contributed again to kind of some of the behaviours that I then developed. So, for example, she's very academically talented. She does work very hard and I'm obviously very,
这两件事是不一样的。是的，完全正确。我认为这对我很重要。比较绝对是我的快乐杀手。事实上，它就像是生活的杀手。我的意思是，我在成长过程中经常拿自己和姐姐比较，我认为这再次导致了我后来发展出的一些行为。例如，她在学术上非常有天赋。她确实非常努力，我显然为她感到非常、
very proud of her. And she is now studying at Cambridge. She's doing aerospace engineering. And I think when she got into Cambridge, I actually cried. As much as I was happy for her, I just obviously that comparison had crept in. And there is no hard feelings between us. we are close but obviously like I kind of latched on to that but then now I kind of look at it and I'm like but I don't want to do aerospace engineering at Cambridge so why am I getting so worked up over this kind of thing so I think it's really about focusing on your values and realizing like what you want to do and not doing things just because other people are doing it if everybody was the same it would be so boring like we're different for a reason and I think it's really important to
非常自豪。她现在在剑桥大学学习。她正在攻读航空航天工程。我想当她进入剑桥时，我真的哭了。尽管我为她感到高兴，但我显然那种比较已经潜入了。我们之间没有隔阂，我们很亲近，但显然我有点纠结于此，但现在我回过头来看，我想，但我不想在剑桥做航空航天工程，所以我为什么要为这种事情如此激动呢？所以我认为这确实是关于专注于你的价值观，并意识到你想要做什么，而不是仅仅因为别人在做就去做。如果每个人都一样，那会很无聊，我们不同是有原因的，我认为记住这一点非常重要。
remember that. Yeah. You do the aerospace engineering in Cambridge and I'll meet you for shopping and an afternoon tea there. Exactly. And maybe punting on the river and that, that will be lovely. But I don't want to do the aerospace engineering. Exactly. Because we are different people and those differences should be celebrated and nor does she want to pursue a psychology career and that has to be okay. No, exactly. Yeah. Like she hates writing essays and I hate doing maths all the time. So it is like completely different. Yeah, absolutely. I'm aware there's a book called I had a black dog that I often used to use in adult mental health services. And that is the idea of externalisation. That is the idea that I think Winston and Churchill first kind of started talking about.
是的。你在剑桥做航空航天工程，我会去那里找你购物和喝下午茶。完全正确。也许还有在河上撑船，那会很棒。但我不想做航空航天工程。完全正确。因为我们是不同的人，这些差异应该被庆祝，她也不想追求心理学职业，那也必须是可以的。不，完全正确。是的。就像她讨厌写论文，而我讨厌一直做数学。所以这完全不同。是的，绝对。我知道有一本书叫《我有一只黑狗》（I had a black dog），我过去常在成人心理健康服务中使用它。这就是外化的概念。我认为温斯顿·丘吉尔（Winston Churchill）首先开始谈论这个。
The idea that you could separate low mood and depression from the person and talk about it to something different. So throughout the book, this black dog kind of gets carted around different areas of the areas of this person's life, it shows up in their relationships, it shows up in their sleep, it shows up with the way they're thinking about themselves. And this can be sometimes a helpful way of helping the family surrounding the person that's experiencing an eating disorder, but also the person themselves to begin to get a little bit of leverage to separate themselves from the presentation. So maybe not a black dog, but we've used all the sorts of different things. People might call it like an orc from Lord of the Rings. They might be like
你可以将低落的情绪和抑郁与个人分开，并谈论它作为不同的东西。所以整本书中，这只黑狗被带到这个人生活的不同领域，它出现在他们的人际关系中，出现在他们的睡眠中，出现在他们思考自己的方式中。这有时可以成为帮助围绕进食障碍患者的家庭，以及患者本人开始获得一点杠杆作用，将自己与表现区分开来的有用方法。所以也许不是黑狗，但我们使用了各种不同的东西。人们可能会称之为像《指环王》里的半兽人。他们可能是
the dark thing or, you know, the spiky thoughts or the, you know, the poison or they, it's important that they would kind of name this themselves or that you help them to work through how it feels or how it sounds. What's your kind of stance on externalising eating disorders, Tiffany? Yeah, of course I think it's really important. And I think, again, it differs for everybody's So some people, for example, found it helpful to give it a name, and then it was almost like another identity in a sense. For me, like I said, it wasn't necessarily given it a name, but identifying it as this part of me that needed that support and that care.
黑暗的东西，或者，你知道，尖锐的想法，或者，你知道，毒药，或者他们，重要的是他们自己命名这个，或者你帮助他们理清它的感觉或听起来的样子。你对进食障碍外化的立场是什么，蒂芙尼？是的，当然，我认为这非常重要。而且我认为，同样，它因人而异。所以有些人，例如，发现给它起个名字很有帮助，然后它几乎就像是另一种身份。对我来说，就像我说的，不一定是给它起个名字，而是将其识别为我身体里需要那种支持和关怀的部分。
And that was preventing me from living life in line with my values. So I think that's how I looked at it. And I think, again, it's really important that other people are really aware of maybe the language they're using or how they're approaching that individual and really realizing that this, the eating disorder is kind of like masking that person behind it
这阻止了我按照我的价值观生活。所以我认为这就是我看待它的方式。而且我认为，同样，其他人真正意识到他们可能使用的语言或他们接近那个人的方式，并真正意识到进食障碍就像是在掩盖背后的人，这一点非常重要。
and it's really about breaking down that wall and looking beyond it. And yeah, I think it's true, like it does feel like a constant weight. Like it goes with you everywhere. It obviously goes with you to the dining table, but then it goes with you to when you sleep, when you're having social interactions.
这确实是关于打破那堵墙并看向它之外。是的，我认为这是真的，它确实感觉像是一个持续的负担。它和你一起去任何地方。它显然和你一起去餐桌，但当你睡觉时，当你进行社交互动时，它也和你在一起。
And it is like this, heavy weight and for me it kind of felt like this like just dark mass i guess um that was constantly like spinning around in my head and i think it becomes so easy to think it is you and that is who you are but actually it's not um that's not you it's just at the moment it's bigger than the part that allows you to live life in line with how you want to yeah and i think it's even more complicated because for the family it feels like it's an enemy, like a bad thing. Doesn't always feel like that to the person that's got, you know, the difficulties going on themselves. Yeah, exactly.
这就像这个沉重的负担，对我来说，它感觉就像这个黑暗的团块，我想，它一直在我的脑海里旋转。而且我认为很容易认为它就是你，那就是你是谁，但实际上它不是，那不是你，它只是目前比那个让你按照你想要的方式生活的你更大。是的，而且我认为这更复杂，因为对于家庭来说，它感觉像是一个敌人，像一个坏东西。对于患有这些困难的人自己来说，并不总是那样感觉。是的，完全正确。
I think I spent so much of my time recovering or even before I was actively recovering, just thinking this is my fault, I chose this. Like I don't deserve recovery. Again, that really self-critical voice coming in. And I think that's where it's so important for that externalisation. It's realising, no, you did not choose this. No one would choose to have an eating disorder. I fail to believe that.
我想我花了很多时间在康复中，甚至在我积极康复之前，只是认为这是我的错，我选择了这个。就像我不配康复。同样，那个真正自我批评的声音进来了。我认为这就是外化如此重要的地方。这是意识到，不，你没有选择这个。没有人会选择患上进食障碍。我不相信这一点。
And that we just ended up here. Like, we're all humans. We didn't choose to be here either. We just ended up here. And it's about really just working with that individual in helping them to kind of, I guess, live life. live life in line with how they want to. Yeah, absolutely. Just before we finish,
我们只是最终到了这里。就像，我们都是人类。我们也没有选择来到这里。我们只是最终到了这里。这是关于真正与那个人合作，帮助他们，我想，生活。按照他们想要的方式生活。是的，绝对。在我们结束之前，
I'm reminded of a really lovely episode that I did with a very inspiring trainee psychologist called Jacob, and he's care experienced. And he really does great work around talking about the importance of knowing the impact of being care experienced and also how it can be really validating and can really help rapport and for everybody to do a bit of a deep exhale, to have people that are care experienced in services supporting young people
我想起了一个我与一位非常鼓舞人心的实习心理学家雅各布（Jacob）做的非常可爱的节目，他有护理经验。他在谈论了解护理经验的影响的重要性方面做得很好，而且它也可以非常具有验证性，并能真正帮助建立融洽关系，让每个人都深呼吸，让有护理经验的人在服务中支持年轻人，
who are living in care or having care experiences as they grow. Would you say it's important to do a little bit of self-disclosure if someone is working in eating disorders and has had that experience themselves? It's always difficult as a clinician, isn't it? but what's your opinion? Personally, I think lived experience is so important in these settings. And I think for me, like, I would have wanted more of that when I was going through treatment. And I understand that obviously there are kind of like boundaries that are set.
那些生活在护理中或在成长过程中有护理经验的人。你会说如果有人在进食障碍领域工作并且自己也有过那种经历，进行一点自我披露很重要吗？作为临床医生总是很困难，不是吗？但你的意见是什么？就我个人而言，我认为生活经验在这些环境中非常重要。而且我认为对我来说，我希望在接受治疗时能有更多这样的经历。而且我理解显然有设定的界限。
But I personally don't see the harm in someone disclosing lived experience if they're working as a clinician. Obviously, this is up to them to disclose. and I guess it's down to that individual to be really bounderied with what they share or kind of like how much they can support someone. But I think it is just so helpful. Like you said, it just, that individual understands what it's like to have lived it. And I think sometimes it can feel like you're being treated out of a textbook. And I'm not saying that clinicians without lived experience aren't as good.
但我个人认为，如果有人作为临床医生工作，披露生活经验并没有什么害处。显然，这取决于他们是否披露。而且我想这取决于那个人在分享什么或他们能支持某人多少方面真正设定界限。但我认为这真的很有帮助。就像你说的，它只是，那个人理解经历过它是什么感觉。而且我认为有时感觉你是在照本宣科地被治疗。我并不是说没有生活经验的临床医生就不那么好。
That's definitely not true. But again, I just see so much value in kind of, of having that shared experience. But it is tricky and I think it will really vary from person to person. I know as a clinician in the future I would want to share my experience and my story. Yeah, and I obviously spend a lot of time supporting aspiring psychologist and I'm a curious scientist practitioner. I don't know whether there's potentially room. We've spent a lot of time talking about service user involvement and kind of service user led research. But for me, feels like if this isn't already happening in services for people with eating disorders,
那绝对不是真的。但同样，我只是在拥有那种共同经验方面看到了很多价值。但这很棘手，我认为它确实会因人而异。我知道作为未来的临床医生，我想分享我的经历和故事。是的，我显然花了很多时间支持有抱负的心理学家，我是一名好奇的科学家实践者。我不知道是否有可能有空间。我们花了很多时间谈论服务用户参与和某种服务用户主导的研究。但对我来说，感觉如果这还没有在进食障碍患者的服务中发生，
that it would be really great to have even a group that runs once a week or once every few weeks where people who have been through this and have obviously been kind of trained and guided by the clinicians in the service but are there to be with people so that they can show them what recovery might look like and so that you really are singing from that hymn sheet. And when I've I've worked with people with eating disorders, they haven't been able to find anybody who actively talks about being recovered so they can see what that looks like. There's lots and lots of narratives around people who are still struggling, but not so much around. Look how glorious life can be when you are recovered.
那么拥有一个每周或每几周运行一次的小组会很棒，在那里经历过这一切的人，并且显然已经接受了服务中临床医生的培训和指导，但他们在那里是为了与人们在一起，这样他们就可以向他们展示康复可能是什么样子，这样你们就真的在同一个频道上。当我与进食障碍患者一起工作时，他们无法找到任何积极谈论康复的人，这样他们就能看到那是什么样子。有很多关于仍在挣扎的人的叙述，但关于“看看当你康复时生活是多么辉煌”的叙述却不多。
Yeah, and I think, unfortunately, there is a little bit of kind of like catching up to do with that. I think a lot of services are starting to implement. men expert by experience talks and maybe groups that have involvement of like lived experience perspectives. This is something I have started doing. But I do think it's something that should be kind of compulsory in all services, to be honest. I think it is key to the treatment and in recovery to have that kind of opportunity to talk to someone who's been through it and just to feel empowered really in their recovery. And I think, like, for me, that is the most important work that I do is, like, the expert by experience talks and being able to kind of sit with someone.
是的，而且我认为，不幸的是，在这方面还有一点需要赶上。我认为许多服务机构开始实施“经验专家”讲座，也许还有涉及生活经验视角的团体。这是我开始做的事情。但我确实认为，老实说，这应该是所有服务机构的强制性要求。我认为与经历过它的人交谈，并真正感到在康复中获得力量，是治疗和康复的关键。而且我认为，对我来说，我所做的最重要的工作就是“经验专家”讲座，并能够与某人坐在一起。
They're like, you just, you get me. That's what I'm going through. Like, I've never heard anyone, like, make me feel so understood before. And it is because, obviously, you are both going through that specific thing. it's difficult because obviously again if you're doing lived experience work you have to be in that position where you're you aren't going to get triggered and it is really really important that you put yourself first so it took me a while to get into the work that I do and like the lived experience research that I do as well but just like hearing how helpful it is to all the individuals that I speak with I just really hope it is something that becomes compulsory in all services yeah and like you said I'd echo that you absolutely don't know need to have had an eating disorder yourself to be a really effective clinician in that service but I think we can all learn so much from people who have had first-hand experience of this. Let's think more about where we can learn about you and your work. Where can people
他们就像，你真的，你懂我。这就是我正在经历的。就像，我以前从未听过任何人让我感到如此被理解。这是因为，显然，你们都在经历那件具体的事情。这很困难，因为显然如果你在做生活经验工作，你必须处于那种你不会被触发的位置，而且你把自己放在第一位真的非常非常重要。所以我花了一段时间才进入我所做的工作，以及我所做的生活经验研究，但只是听到它对所有我交谈过的人有多大帮助，我真的希望它成为所有服务机构的强制性要求。是的，就像你说的，我会附和这一点，你绝对不需要自己患过进食障碍才能成为该服务中非常有效的临床医生，但我认为我们都可以从那些对此有第一手经验的人那里学到很多。让我们多想想我们可以在哪里了解你和你的工作。人们可以在哪里
check out your TEDx for example? Yes, so I did a TEDx talk last year, which I still can't quite believe that actually did, given someone that hated public speaking literally like a year ago. So it is on YouTube. I guess it will be linked below as well. I also am developing a website at the moment where you'll be able to access my lived experience resources that I've created. I found that obviously I was going to different services
查看你的TEDx演讲，例如？是的，我去年做了一个TEDx演讲，我仍然不敢相信我真的做了，考虑到我直到一年前还讨厌公开演讲。所以它在YouTube上。我想它也会在下面链接。我目前也在开发一个网站，你将能够访问我创建的生活经验资源。我发现显然我要去不同的服务机构
and contributing these resources, but obviously being a full-time student, I'm working. I wasn't able to kind of reach lots of individuals. So I'm like, if I've got these resources, I might as well put them out there. So there'll be free downloadable. resources such as posters and workbooks, which will be uploaded online. So the website's called the recovery wave. And I guess that really reflects how recovery is up and down, but ultimately it
并贡献这些资源，但显然作为一名全日制学生，我在工作。我无法接触到很多人。所以我说，如果我有这些资源，我不如把它们放出来。所以会有免费的可下载资源，如海报和练习册，它们将在线上传。所以网站叫“康复浪潮”（The recovery wave）。我想这确实反映了康复是如何起伏不定的，但最终它
does lead to a beautiful thing. And also I'll be uploading resources for students, for trainee clinicians, for professionals working in eating disorders. And their training resources kind of covering a whole range of different topics as well. Great. Thank you. And what's your username on LinkedIn in case anyone wants to follow you there? Yeah, so my LinkedIn is Tiffany Luxford. And Luxford is L-U-X-F-O-R-D. Yeah, that's correct. Amazing. Thank you so much for sharing your knowledge
确实导致了一件美好的事情。而且我还会上传供学生、实习临床医生、在进食障碍领域工作的专业人士使用的资源。他们的培训资源涵盖了一系列不同的主题。太棒了。谢谢。如果有人想在领英上关注你，你的用户名是什么？是的，我的领英是蒂芙尼·勒克斯福德（Tiffany Luxford）。勒克斯福德是L-U-X-F-O-R-D。是的，没错。太棒了。非常感谢你如此热情和慷慨地与我们分享你的知识
and your experience with us so warmly and so generously. I hope this does help people. And if people have found this helpful, please do drop us a comment. please do follow us on socials, tag us on socials because it's always really lovely knowing when this resonates. Thank you again for your time, Tiffany. Thank you so much. I really appreciate it.
和你的经验。我希望这确实能帮助到人们。如果人们觉得这有帮助，请给我们留言。请在社交媒体上关注我们，在社交媒体上标记我们，因为知道这引起了共鸣总是非常好的。再次感谢你的时间，蒂芙尼。非常感谢。我真的很感激。
It's always a pleasure to kind of talk about my experience and have the opportunity to kind of get the word out there really. Thank you so much for your time and for pitching to me too. Thank you. Bye. Thank you so much for watching or listening to this stage and for Tiffany's time in speaking with us. We were really careful about how we phrased things
能够分享我的经历并有机会宣传这些信息，我总是感到非常荣幸。非常感谢您抽出时间，也感谢您向我推介。谢谢。再见。非常感谢您观看或收听本期节目，也感谢蒂芙尼抽出时间与我们交谈。我们在措辞和表达方式上非常谨慎，
and how we wanted to put things across. So we hope this has not been a triggering episode for you. Of course, sometimes realisations and breakthroughs happen and you think actually now is the time for me to access some treatment, support or advice. Please do check out the NHS guidance and advice for people that are experiencing eating disorders. There's also beat eating disorders.
我们希望这期节目不会给您带来负面情绪。当然，有时当您意识到问题并取得突破时，您可能会觉得现在是寻求治疗、支持或建议的时候了。请务必查看英国国家医疗服务体系（NHS）为饮食失调患者提供的指导和建议。此外还有“Beat”饮食失调慈善机构。
and do consider contacting Shout or the Samaritans for advice or support too. It's also very important to be supported and understood and validated if you love someone who is experiencing an eating disorder. So please do take a look at the resources on those websites that are there specifically for you too. I enjoy connecting with Gemma Oten, who is over on LinkedIn and also has her own. charity, which was born of her own struggles with eating disorders. So do check out the seed eating disorders service too. Thank you so much for being here. If you like the idea of externalisation and you'd like to learn more about it, it's a little technique borrowed from
也请考虑联系“Shout”或“撒玛利亚会”寻求建议或支持。如果您所爱的人正在经历饮食失调，获得支持、理解和认同也非常重要。因此，请务必查看这些网站上专门为您提供的资源。我很喜欢与杰玛·奥滕（Gemma Oten）交流，她在领英上很活跃，也有自己的慈善机构，该机构源于她自己与饮食失调的斗争。所以也请查看“Seed”饮食失调服务。非常感谢您的收听。如果您喜欢“外化”这个概念并想了解更多，这是一种借鉴自
narrative therapy. And you can check out the recent episode I did with a lovely trio of psychologists all looking into older adult work and narrative therapy. Pete. There's so much to learn there. Hope that you will love it if you do check it out. And if you do have any comments about that episode or this episode or any of my content, if you're loving it, I really like it. When you tag me, when you share it on socials, when you tell your friends, your family. So please do come and connect with me on social media. I'm Dr. Marianne Trent everywhere. If like Tiffany, you're an aspiring psychologist, I think you'd really enjoy the aspiring psychologist membership, which you can join from just £30 a month with no minimum term.
叙事疗法的小技巧。您可以查看我最近与三位可爱的心理学家合作的节目，她们都专注于老年人工作和叙事疗法。皮特，那里有很多值得学习的东西。希望您在查看后会喜欢它。如果您对那一期或这一期节目，或者我的任何内容有任何评论，如果您喜欢的话，我真的很开心。当您在社交媒体上标记我、分享它，或者告诉您的朋友和家人时，我都会很高兴。所以请务必在社交媒体上与我联系。我在所有平台上的名字都是玛丽安·特伦特（Dr. Marianne Trent）博士。如果您像蒂芙尼一样是一位有抱负的心理学家，我想您会非常喜欢“有抱负的心理学家会员计划”，您只需每月支付30英镑即可加入，且没有最低期限要求。
It's your way of gaining insight, experiences and confidence to help you springboard to the next step of your psychology career. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是您获得洞察力、经验和信心，帮助您迈向心理学职业生涯下一步的途径。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。